40歲的年輕的工程師來講
他超慢跑
再搭配飲食之後
糖化血色素
從12降到6.2
高血壓從180降到117
他的三高真的
就是慢慢的遞減
三個月
他就瘦了20公斤
的肌力訓練
有深蹲
伏地推撐
每天只要
鍛鍊10分鐘左右
就能預防跌倒
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
各位粉絲們好
我在節目裡頭
曾經介紹過超慢跑
滿受歡迎的
今天我特別為你
邀請到
邀請到超慢跑的權威
他是幫助很多
熟齡朋友們
找回健康的體適能專家
歡迎徐棟英徐教官
嗨 胡醫師好
各位觀眾大家好
今天要和你分享
超慢跑怎麼跑
不傷膝蓋 抗三高
你是否有肌少症的風險
預防跌倒的秘訣
讓你在
人生的下半場
活力滿滿不失能
超慢跑有多厲害
它強心肺
控三高
徐教官
有粉絲問我
他說他年紀大了
血壓血糖都不穩定
開始超慢跑以後
竟然血糖比較穩定
你帶的學員裡面
有多少三高的案例
其實有很多粉絲們
跟著做超慢跑之後
他的三高確實
有降下來的效果
效果很好
我舉一個
40歲的年輕的工程師來講
他超慢跑
再搭配飲食之後
他的糖化血色素
從12降到6.2
那他的高血壓
從180降到117左右
那他的血脂
從230
降到160 170左右
所以他的三高真的
就是慢慢的遞減
三個月
他就瘦了20公斤
太棒了
那另外一個是65歲的
他只花兩個月
他就是每天追劇超慢跑
大概跑兩個小時左右
就達到兩萬步
他兩個月
就從200降到86
回到三酸甘油酯的標準值
待會徐教官還會
跟你分享超慢跑
怎麼跑才有效
怎麼跑才不傷膝蓋
一定要看到最後喔
真的 很多醫師和營養師
也都鼓勵糖友
從超慢跑開始
而且不用出門喔
你就直接
用完餐以後你就在家
本來要散步的
改成超慢跑
它對飯後的
血糖穩定效果很好
用餐完
多久的時間可以跑呢
你只要
休息三五分鐘
就可以跑了
三五分鐘就可以
對 為什麼呢
因為它也不是很激烈的
對 它不是很激烈
最重要的是
當你坐下沙發或躺下來
你就絕對會等下一次了
你不可能馬上起來跑
那你就會懶惰嘛
記得徐教官的這時候建議喔
你們可以
從今天開始就跑一跑
其實超慢跑
只是我的課程的小菜一碟
我真正的主菜是核心
人要活得健康
其實就是
核心肌肉要有力量
就我們身體的重心嘛
我們的重心肌肉
沒有力量
所以你行動就會受限
所以走路變慢
行動力不好
然後開始腰痠背痛
肩頸痠痛
那甚至膝蓋不舒服
所以我們必須要透過一些
阻力訓練 肌力訓練
來讓我們的肌肉
變得有力量有彈性
你的活動力才會變好
腰痠背痛
爬樓梯吃力
2動作檢測肌少症
根據你的經驗
有哪些徵兆
可以檢測自己
是不是有了
所謂的肌少症的現象
假如說覺得自己
從床上要起床
感覺很吃力
另外呢 看到矮凳子
不敢坐下來
然後呢爬樓梯用手在爬樓梯
或者坐轎車出不來
都要用手去扳腳的
這些都是肌少的現象
已經慢慢開始
影響你的生活
對 這一定影響生活
再來我們可以
透過兩個動作
來檢測你的肌力的狀況
第一個是等長捲腹 60秒鐘
等長捲腹是檢測你的
肩頸有沒有力量
第二個是直膝舉腿
直膝舉腿是檢測你的
腰腹部的肌肉力量
是不是穩定
那我們做的是一個
等長捲腹
請各位躺下來以後
兩腳屈膝打開 約肩寬
腳不要太開
在你的臀部正後方
那你的雙手放在大腿上
那捲腹上來的時候呢
手指頭跟頭跟肩膀
慢慢的往膝蓋方向抬
這個動作
停滯在最高點一分鐘
好來
來我們準備囉
好慢慢捲腹上來開始
10秒
這時候
你要維持正常呼吸喔
20秒
你假如撐不住的
可以把你的膝蓋
腳抱起來
30秒
記得把你的下巴緊扣
不要往後仰
40秒
好慢慢的
回到休息的狀態
這個就是等長捲腹
這個動作
在做的時候呢
假如這塊肌肉不好
你的頭跟肩膀
就會一直往下掉
那你假如說往下掉
就表示這塊肌肉
它不能持久
那其實相對人的肩頸
就會代償很嚴重
所以這裡不好
肩頸跟著不好
做這個動作之前
我會先加一個動作
就是屈膝伸腿
那我們現在
來做動作示範
我們先做的第一個
躺下來檢測屈膝
是不是可以小於90度
那我們先將手壓在地板
兩腳屈膝併腿騰空
把腳盡量縮近肚子
讓你的腳
產生角度是小於90度
這樣是小於90度
這樣是概約90度
你假如說
可以縮近肚子
小於90度的時候呢
這表示你的髖關節
是還好的
那我們
在做直膝舉腿的時候
我們再來檢查
你的髖關節是不是
可以舉到小於90度
請各位雙手
壓在地板上
兩腳膝蓋伸直併攏
那我們這個動作
做一個簡單檢測
我們做三下就好
來準備了
吸氣慢慢縮縮上來
吐氣慢慢下來
吸氣上來
那很多觀眾
剛開始的時候
會出現什麼狀況呢
他屈膝是很容易
做到小於90度
但是直膝的時候
他可能因為
這塊肌肉沒有力量
他會出現這樣子
舉到這裡就卡住了
那就表示
這塊肌肉沒有力量
你的背就是纖維化
這個就是一個
髖關節退化所引起的
那假如說
你不趕快
練這塊肌肉的話
你未來會
一直使用大腿走路
大腿走路爬樓梯
最後你的膝蓋
就開始痛
所以你要改善這個
請你慢慢練
先做屈膝再做直膝
效果就很好
年長族最怕跌倒
高CP值運動
增肌防跌倒
年長的朋友
最怕的不是生病
是突然跌倒
尤其是在浴室廚房
那種又濕又滑的地板
不小心重心不穩
就啪一聲摔下去
四腳朝天
骨折住院 就很麻煩了
徐教官這樣子
這種突然的沒力的狀況
我們要怎麼樣
才能保護自己不受傷
最重要關鍵
還是要鍛鍊核心肌群
核心肌群
它是一個安全氣囊
當你在危機發生的時候
它可以啟動你的核心
穩定重心
這時候可以
降低傷害的風險
是喔
我會給各位介紹
三個高CP值的肌力訓練
有深蹲
伏地推撐
伏地推撐 棒式
每天只要鍛鍊10分鐘左右
把你的核心肌肉
練起來以後
就能預防跌倒
好 我們現在
要給各位介紹的是深蹲
深蹲有一個
很重要的技巧要領
就是你的重心
要落在腳後跟
那重心在腳後跟
膝蓋就不會
有過前的問題
那請各位跟著我做
腳打開約肩寬或略寬
柔軟度差一點的
建議寬一點
比肩膀寬一點
那重心在腳後跟
那先啟動
你的髖關節往後推
讓你的臀大肌拉到最長
重心在腳後跟
腳趾頭翹起來
吸氣慢慢下蹲
手肘放膝蓋 抬頭挺胸
吐氣慢慢站立起來
吸氣下蹲
我會建議
所有的觀眾呢
每週做兩到三天就夠了
就是間隔一兩天做
就是一個禮拜
做兩到三次
一次做兩到三組
那這個深蹲
一個動作可以動員
刺激人體70%左右的肌肉
它的CP值很高
現在給各位
介紹第二個高CP值的動作
是伏地推撐
他訓練我們的上半身肌肉
那它是透過手掌推撐
帶動你的肩關節
來訓練你的胸大肌
跟肩胛骨肌肉
肘關節動的時候
讓你的二頭三頭肌肉
產生等張收縮
手腕關節
讓你的橈腕前側後側
所以你一這樣趴下來
把身體推起來
就把你上半身肌肉建置好
那我會介紹
入門版
初階版
中階版
然後標準版
我們做四個動作
那因為時間的關係
我們每一個動作
做兩下就好
那你就去做這個動作
萬一你做不到
其他三個動作
你就先做最入門初階的
做十下
每一組做十下
一次做兩組左右
你的效果
就會慢慢練起來
那這個動作
練好以後
可以有效解除
你的肩頸痠痛
甚至偏頭痛
那偏頭痛的誘因
通常是這個
斜方肌纖維化所引起
我訓練很多銀髮族
本來都要吃藥
偏頭痛誘發的頭痛
訓練大概三個月
到半年以後他偏頭痛
不藥而癒
所以我介紹這個很重要
我希望各位觀眾
能夠慢慢認真學習
第一個
我們先做的是跪膝肘撐
那怎麼做呢
它有一點像棒式
請各位先趴下來
趴下來最重要的是
你的肩關節要趴下來
你最好用
你的下巴去碰到瑜伽墊
那這時候肩關節
盡量越接近地板越好
這時候我們是跪膝肘撐
所以我們膝蓋跪著
各位觀眾
可以看我做示範
慢慢推撐起來
把身體推離地板
慢慢屈肘下來
慢慢推撐起來
這樣往返10次
效果就很好
當你這個動作
做得越來越輕鬆
那你就做直膝肘撐
膝蓋要離地囉
一樣肩關節要趴下來
下巴盡量碰到瑜伽墊
慢慢推撐起來
把身體整個撐起來
像棒式一樣
慢慢屈肘下來
慢慢推撐起來
把身體撐離地板
慢慢屈肘下來
這樣也是往返10次
當你這個動作
越做越好
我們再進階到用手掌撐
我們這個叫跪膝掌撐
那你手掌
在推的點要放在哪裡
不要太前面
一定盡量往後拉
拉到你的
手腕手肘盡量垂直
手腕跟手肘垂直
那這樣推的時候用掌根
手指頭微微打開
用掌根來推
一樣下巴碰瑜伽墊
慢慢推撐起來
把身體推離地板
跪著膝蓋
慢慢屈肘下來
慢慢推撐起來
這樣來回一樣10次
慢慢屈肘下來
這樣子
做得很好的以後呢
我們再把膝蓋離開
就是標準版的
慢慢推撐起來
把身體推離地板
慢慢屈肘下來
慢慢推撐起來
我訓練銀髮族十幾年來
我的觀察
你只要做了就會進步
不要否定現在的你
當你越做越好的時候
當你肌肉好的時候
你就可以解除
你身體的不舒服
好
最後一個動作
要給各位介紹的是棒式
那這個動作呢
其實它是
練你的腰腹部核心
那我們剛剛介紹前面兩個
一個是深蹲
是練你的下肢
伏地挺身 練你的上肢
棒式 練你的核心
這三個動作
你只要每天有空
做三個動作乘以兩組
大概六分鐘
每一個動作一分鐘
六分鐘 然後中間休息三十秒
十分鐘就可以
把你的身體健身好
那我們現在來給
各位介紹棒式要怎麼做
好 請各位一樣慢慢的趴下來
兩手肘約肩寬
那怎麼檢查約肩寬呢
把兩個手交叉
那手交叉的時候
這個就剛好約肩寬的動作
那你的手慢慢打開
你可以平行放
也可以三角形放
那這隨個人的習慣
那最重要的是什麼
你的肩膀手肘要垂直
你不要一開始就做錯了
這時候肩膀落後於手肘
這時候
你撐起來會很費力
那你也不要這樣子
這個又太窄
太斜了也不行
所以在做的時候
肩膀手肘把它垂直
這個很重要
好 那約肩寬
兩腳拱起來
腳趾頭碰地
那你的脖子
盡量看著地板
頸椎看著地板
不要抬頭
也不要低頭
好 準備囉
準備計時喔
來 撐體開始
用力縮腹 核心拉直
這時候呢 有六個要領
第一個 你的頭擺正
不要低頭 也不要抬頭
第二個
10秒
肩膀手肘垂直
第三個 用力縮腹
第四個 用力夾臀
第五個 膝蓋挺直
第六個 你的腳踝 足踝部成90度
那你在做的過程當中
腹腔盡量縮緊
30秒
然後呢
在你的胸腔慢慢吸吐氣
40秒
初學的人可以30秒
也可以60秒
量力而為 慢慢做 你會越做越久
50秒
60秒到
好
這個就是棒式
台灣不健康餘命
7.78年
這樣做避免失能臥床
根據2023年的統計
台灣人的
不健康餘命
有7.78年
代表什麼呢
代表人生的最後
有差不多八年的時間
是臥床
失能
需要他人照顧
的這種狀況下
度過的
別等到你倒下了才後悔喔
我們如果
把身體顧好不臥床
更不要連累孩子好不好
我常說
寧可在瑜伽墊多流汗
少躺在病床上流眼淚
想要預防臥床
我建議你
常常做這幾個動作
譬如說
捲腹
第二個 腳踏車捲腹
第三個 手碰腳跟的捲腹
這三個動作
你只要把正面核心
跟兩側腹部核心練好
所以你就不會臥床了
為各位介紹
避免臥床的
主要訓練的肌群
第一個
我們要訓練的
是這一塊
叫腹直肌的源頭
它長在哪裡呢
長在胸肋骨下面
就是腹直肌的上面四塊
這個肌肉
假如失能的話
你起床就需要人家
扶你的頭跟肩膀抱起來
它就是被照顧的開始
各位請看我做示範
因為拍攝的關係
我們每一個動作
只做三到五下
或三到五組
這個動作都是一樣
每一個動作
都要做到十下或十組
請各位慢慢看我做示範
請所有的觀眾
一樣慢慢的坐下來以後
兩腳屈膝
一樣打開約肩寬
腳後跟在
屁股臀部的正後方
雙手放在大腿上
捲腹上來的時候
手指頭跟頭跟肩膀
一樣慢慢捲腹上來
然後再慢慢的躺下來
那你躺下來
最好手肘碰地
你的頭跟肩膀
不落地更好
萬一真的受不了
你就落地也沒關係
這個概念
來準備囉
我們做三下就好
手放大腿
來準備好了
預備開始
1 2 3
上來吐氣
3 2 1
2 2 3
3 2 3
3 2 1
4 2 3
5 2 3
3 2 1
這個就是
捲腹訓練這塊
腹直肌的源頭
這個肌肉
熟齡族
運動注意事項
熟齡族的族群
他們在運動的時候
容易犯哪些錯誤
怎麼樣來避免受傷
其實我認為熟齡族
因為肌肉太少去訓練它
然後他會很緊張
緊張我們用力的時候
就容易憋氣
憋氣會造成甚麼
頭暈
會缺氧
這時候就容易受傷
所以我們記得
我們在訓練肌力訓練的時候
要注意到呼吸
透過呼吸節奏
讓我們的肌肉盡量放鬆
而達到訓練的效果
降血壓的關鍵動作
等長收縮
等長收縮的訓練是什麼
根據英國運動醫學期刊
他的研究顯示了
他說長期練習
所謂的
所謂的等長收縮運動
能夠降血壓
讓血壓更穩定
徐教官很多人他就不能夠
了解什麼是等長收縮
可以跟我們的粉絲們
說明一下嗎
其實我們
肌肉訓練有兩種模式
一個讓肌肉產生等張收縮
第二種是等長收縮
等張收縮可能
讓我們的肌肉
保持一個彈性跟柔韌度
等長收縮
是讓你的肌肉耐受度變好
那老人家
其實等長收縮更為重要
因為你的肌肉耐受度不好
就容易發生意外
就突然之間
無力感就跌倒了
所以你的肌肉耐受度越好
它對老人家來講越好
我這樣解釋好了
像我們徒手
在做的伏地挺身
趴下來推起來趴下來推起來
這反覆距離是一樣
叫等張收縮
那我們經常
聽到的棒式有沒有
撐在地板上肌肉長度不變
然後讀秒的
用讀秒撐在那裡叫等長收縮
超慢跑怎麼跑才對
膝蓋受傷也能跑嗎
我們在超慢跑的時候呢
什麼樣的動作
才是最好的
那我現在給
所有的觀眾介紹四個技巧
跟四個口訣
那我們最重要
有四個技巧
第一個技巧呢
腳掌先著地
再腳後跟輕碰地板
各位觀眾
可以看到
我的腳掌先落地
腳後跟輕碰地板
那腳後跟 似有似無最好
這是第一個技巧
腳掌先著地
再腳後跟輕碰地板
第二個技巧
膝蓋微曲
各位觀眾
看我的膝關節
它是沒有伸直過的
它的關節
是完全是微曲的
第三個
要節能減碳
跑步的時候呢
要落地的聲音
感覺在練輕功一樣
就越輕量越好
那第四個呢
要達到節能減碳
最好的方法
就是小步伐高步頻
一分鐘180步
你就跟上這個節拍
放輕鬆的律動
那傾聽身體四個口訣
這個四個口訣
就是身體的回饋
不痠
不痛
不硬
不喘
痠痛硬喘不要找你
就可以跑很久
徐教練有一本書喔
聽說是剛剛好一週年是嗎
是
這本書是去年8月7號出刊的
那這本書呢
其實是一個工具書
第二章呢
就是有標準版跟入門版
那有QR code
一掃標準版的動作
就會有親自
喊口令做動作給各位示範
那這第二章就是
我完整的
核心肌肉訓練課程
那第三章有私房菜單
這私房菜單
是我做12年銀髮的心得
跟大家分享
不想腰痠背痛
膝蓋不舒服
請你做這六個動作
你的腰痠背痛
就不會找你麻煩了
那最後一個叫平衡感的
不倒翁訓練
腿部間歇
對年長者來講
這個動作只要做得好
保證你不會跌倒
這平衡感會變很好
所以這本書
很值得推薦
給所有的觀眾
第一題請問
很多朋友想知道
膝蓋正在受傷的人
他們可不可以做超慢跑
我還是建議
先經過醫生的評估
假如覺得腿的受傷
沒有問題的話
沒有大礙的話
你先試看看
原地節拍超慢跑
那腳跑起來
不會不舒服的話
就可以跑
那你跑起來會很不舒服
那當然先不要做
先停一停
第二題
有些人他的腳
沒有力抬起來
這種狀況怎麼樣
來做超慢跑呢
我會建議
他假如說抬腳有疑慮
有困難
可能他平衡感比較差
我會建議他先扶著牆壁
然後跟著節拍器
在原地扶著牆壁
原地節拍超慢跑
腳只要離地一點點
其實你就律動起來
這時候你的行動力
就會慢慢跟著好
當你越跑越好的時候
就可以離開牆壁
像我有一個中風的朋友
他大概六十幾歲
他扶著牆壁
跑一分多鐘而已
就很喘 很累
但是我鼓勵他不要放棄
結果經過三個月以後
他竟然可以跑一個小時
這麼好
第三題
請問超慢跑
每天要運動多久
才會有明顯的效果
又不會累到想放棄呢
其實超慢跑
是一種很有效的有氧運動
一週我們講說
訓練頻率來講
一週五到七天
譬如說你想要減重的
我一個粉絲
他每天累加90到120分鐘
再搭配飲食
譬如我早中晚各三十分鐘
這樣就達到
就一個半鐘頭
對
你可以十分鐘十分鐘十分鐘
累加也沒問題
就是你去累加
你每天的跑量
達到90到120分鐘
對減重減脂很有幫助
搭配飲食
那假如說你要降三高的話
你大概跑十五到三十分鐘
三餐飯後
那其實你這樣跑
十五分鐘乘以三
是不是四十五分鐘
那你假如說血脂要下來的話
大概就是二三十分鐘
那二十分鐘乘以三
也就六十分鐘
其實你的血脂肪
就慢慢下來了
好
今天很開心
徐教官跟我們分享這麼多
讓自己更健康的運動方法
我知道
你不想成為孩子的負擔
健康是給
家人最好的禮物
看完這一集
今天晚上就開始和
兒子女兒老爸老媽動起來
好吧
你還想看我邀請
哪一位專家來跟我對談呢
歡迎在留言區告訴我
喜歡這集內容的
記得點擊超級感謝
把影片分享給更多的人
讓你愛的所有人更健康